this is the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm finally joins it's been a long time
coming and by Steven Joseph who is a
business manager for teacher actives
London branch yep how are you mate
yeah good I'm good I think we can also
say now you're an author yeah so secure
survive thrive which is a treatment but
it is yeah who would have known that you
could create a podcast about recruitment
and books about recruitment yeah not me
not many people would know that there's
that much to talk about
no so we're definitely gonna dive into
this coaches which is really exciting
but as you as you know me what what were
just talking about where I always like
to start is how did Stephen Joseph get
into recruitment mate yeah yeah so
that's a long story as they always are
but um I was what I call her second job
are so recruitment wasn't my first
career you know and I I was in in the
motor trade before part sales and they
did that for like ten years so I had a
whole career but ten years yeah ten
years car sales part sales within mode
so yeah a whole ten years in a different
sector I know right so a long time and
worked my way up and did all those kind
of things so unusually for most people
recruitment usually versus making they
have at the beginning their career and
maybe it's like a complete change and
just because I hit kind of like the
financial ceiling and felt like I could
do more and obviously working around
cars you have a lot of people coming in
and out that doing well for themselves
and you see been working in a city and
you get kind of hearing about where's
your bet whereas you pay all over
southeast southeast London all the way
up to sort Canaan that so many branches
throughout southeast they've got a big
group but in 1999 or 2000 I got made
redundant okay and the company collapsed
and everything fell apart it wasn't him
days and you walk in and someone hands
you a slip and says you don't work here
anymore is one of those situations yeah
but even though I've been there and I
built my whole career around that I was
actually surprisingly positive about
that day because I know I needed to do
something different for a while and I've
got kind of locked into a bubble with
not doing anything about so internally
metaphor and now there's definitely
definitely more your circumstances helps
you yeah a hundred said yeah that hadn't
happened probably would have still doing
something similar because I enjoyed it a
lot but it was just only so far you know
especially when you've done something
for a decade man yeah he's that light at
that point it's like why do you know I
mean that's very difficult to think I'm
gonna have to start something completely
different
yeah yeah and I was quite hopping the
ranks there and you know well for myself
and a big dog for a medium dog okay and
so after redundancy as like okay I
definitely want to be something
different and unlike a lot of recruiters
I'm not from an academic background you
know I don't have a degree or anything
like that so your options are less so
sales is always apart for me mmm and I
was quite drawn to obviously the bright
lights of recruitment and the city and
all that usual stuff so what did you
what was your exposure to recruitment
was it these people driving in Range
Rovers into yeah your branches well more
the jobs they did in people working but
you know you look online for sales jobs
and I was so highest the lowest to place
water and time recruitment came up as a
big thing like that
ot 100k Plus yeah it was still amazing
and and obviously I was him by that so
okay and then and then so then you go
into recruiting at that point yeah so
after that and yeah it was a tough
process for me not being your typical
candidate not being a graduate not being
first job I did not get recruitment job
easily it took time to get one you know
lots of CV sending out and that should
really dress my CV and change my
positioning on things and even then when
I got hired in my first job which is a
little boutique agency and even then
they only gave me one one month
internship is all they would give me yes
so 1,000 pounds flat and yeah for the
first month and they basically decide if
they like to be or not so mental and I
so I didn't get an easy right to begin
with but yeah so that that's how it
always started and that's kind of in the
second chapter of the the career of my
life and then
okay and then just to help me out just
to set the scene yeah how long have you
worked at each Raptor for teacher active
six years this year okay six years and
then before then four years or so in the
boutique so it's about ten years now so
what they catch you off at a thousand
pound yeah obviously a lot of people
would notice now that they part of that
hurry and strategy was always to hire
five people hmm and later only keep two
so obviously I had to find that to
compete for that that was just their
strategy and three they would give jobs
to and two they would give internship to
this was just their their model and
obviously as I discovered it was later I
learned out that I was pumped in to take
a ride okay so you see worked in group
yeah ten years now all education for me
so yeah all educational education all
temp all time obviously we do some perms
but the education model is more dominate
you've been in their education temp
market yeah and you've got another
decade under your belt
yeah of another industry yeah yeah so
what so what would be always keen to get
this like and that beginning stage like
what did your perception of recruitment
start to be then as you start so good
for these processes like would you still
really attracted to it like what made
you persist in that early stage yeah for
me it was like the same thing that drove
me to get into it and I did choose
recruitment and like most people at that
point I was looking to get into it
it was the money obviously I was chasing
money that wasn't really that - did you
have any made some recruitment no not at
that point the stuffing read online yeah
okay and like was he job every job
boards 70% from trainee consult one
isn't it so yeah so yeah so I didn't
want to get into it and I had all the
stereotypical you know views of you know
flush suits and fine lunches and all
that kind of thing and that was the
highlight yeah yeah I always have that
male still chase so that was my view of
it before and obviously as you know some
of that was true some of it not yeah
and and was it was it sold to you like
that as well when he was going for this
process was it very much less Steven
yeah these lights that you're off that
make they're real yeah yeah or that
hundred thousand salad or the classic
yeah all that stuff the cliche stuff
which I think we mostly got away from
now okay we're still right then so why
did you pick that agency out of interest
you know one honestly for me it was more
they would've won the game at each other
yeah it was you know I was looking for
an inn I definitely didn't say out to do
education although I didn't say out to
do any I was always looking for a
recruitment job and it was funny anyone
that would have me at that point and
work my way up I've always been kind of
someone that if I get a job I know my
worth all I'll prove myself when I'm in
there and climb the ranks kind of things
so I wasn't too worried about that but
the education was the first one there
here and to be fed they were they're a
good bunch of guys you know they were
they they were good for what I needed at
the time
how how big was the agency they were
based at a Greenwich in southeast London
they were eight to ten people similar
sites what a year by the time one one
one agency by the time I left same you
know the kind of church that the guys
are owned it used to own a much bigger
firm that they sold capital and this was
their own kind of second go at it but
they've kind of really lost their mojo
is much more of a lifestyle business
okay and how were your first 12 months
in recruitment always horrible mate
horrible really yep horrible yeah and
what were they horrible man
and just because it wasn't very good in
it and the pressures of the job that
ours
not long after being there I really
understood how it all kind of worked and
I was put on performance management and
I've got the pressures of that and you
know that that image are you gonna come
in and a lot of money in a flash lunches
and go nice places and stuff and then
the reality of you know do 12 hours a
day bags under my eyes and then you know
not not getting anywhere and can't catch
a break from no one is you know that's
that's not that's not good the beginning
would you straight I mean I don't know a
whole lot especially mark yeah so was
you straighten they're winning winning
contracts yeah education most branches
in most sectors
sorry most offices is pretty much the
same format education
almost always free 60 and the
consultants obviously do candidate
management they do cold pieces you do
that they want ya the role the actual
role of that hasn't changed much since I
did it from the first day really yeah so
straight in the deep end
yeah winning winning client yeah finding
finding temp teachers yeah to get into
these businesses yeah okay so okay so
those first 12 months then yeah did your
bit all right okay yeah yeah yeah
occurring in the numbers I mean enough
to make it so that but I think it helped
that the colleagues that also started at
the same time didn't do a lot so I was
kind of the best of the bad bunch yeah
and then after that I think you know
just the commitment for I wasn't gonna
let it beat me you know I was gonna
gonna get stuck yeah yeah walk know what
help how do you get through that tough
period then and you know it's like
everyone says you know you've got a you
got to realize where you are I think
there's a lot everyone says oh I thought
I was doing the right things at the time
which I did definitely want the slope in
or anything all that I was doing my work
but as you know like that you can do
your work and then you can do it in a
different way or with a different
attitude yeah just just get more stuck
into it you know and I think once I'd
really learned that and I really started
to ask the right questions and listen to
the garden supposed to be sane properly
rather than just you know think I was
doing what I was being asked to do and
getting fully involved then success
starts come a little bit for me and then
obviously you get more credibility from
your bosses and your team ladies and
stuff like that which helps and then
spiral like the good spiral starts to
happen and once that happened for me and
it was a good 12 18 months in things
actually start to put together quite
quickly yeah so someone that's growing
for a real tough path right now yeah and
they're early on yeah what do you think
they should be thinking about how large
and I mean what I just depends and why
doesn't it I think you know reflections
a real good thing yeah like have a good
worker yourself am I really doing what
on the space to be doing how much of my
heart I'm not going into it I'm really
listening to the guidance I've been told
listening to the right guidance is a
really good thing as well because
recruiters are evil one way or the other
and if you've got a helpful bunch lots
people want to help but sometimes
they're not giving it right
because they're on the same level as you
say a lot of people said it was you
would you say to people like obviously
listen yeah but take what you think's
best of each person then sort of put
your own spin on that yeah I think so
but I think until you know enough about
how to make those calls and think you've
really got to listen to a proven method
yeah assuming the method you listen to
is by you know somebody that's build
well when somebody knows what they're
talking about because sometimes trainees
all grouped together and they will help
you trouble but they're all helping with
bad advice not me okay so what was what
was the journey in this agency there
mate so was it consultant then was using
consortium was yeah and a team by the
time we left
oh that's a good thing so consult and I
forget the tiles it was like senior and
then I think then I had a resource sort
of my own and then I had I think I ended
on divisional manager so I think I ran
the secondary division for them which is
probably about four or five guys that
can after durman when he did I'm four
yeah yeah to be honest he once I've got
my hurdles out the way I got most of
that in a second thirtyish year that
came quite quickly after getting back
together yeah okay so alright before
before we talk a bit about teacher
active and that's on solid solid segment
they're like so you just said you just
said there that after you've got over
that difficult period that twelve
18-month period like things that happen
quite quickly
yeah so firstly why do you think that is
um I think it's I think I always think
it's like effort you know and I was
doing that hours for sure I mean I was
still doing 12 hours a day every day
putting in the effort and the time but I
think how you spend that time gonna be
very different you know you can have 12
hours full-on heading or you can have 12
hours which is really about two hours
worth of work and two hours of not
really engaged and so I think getting
focused on the delivery or the results
that Matt's are what's known what you
need to spend time yeah just getting
your head in it you know if you know
certain things that going to works and
things are not and if you don't know
asking the right people just getting
into the detail quick you know if you're
behind where you need to be you need to
speak someone and say you know what why
am i off track really listen and get
back on that track quickly and I think
if you can do that assuming the guy
that's guiding you just got the
right the right stuff which over you
guys then things should turn quite
quickly what would you go back and do
different in that and they feels to
start your recruitment crits move all of
that may yeah I mean first thing are I
person would do is make not fun over to
big bit of wasn't sit next to him I
think that you know anyone out there
that has in the situation get as close
as you can to the top performers because
they will rub off on you you were here
things you'll follow their attitude and
and that that would be something that's
what a big builder in office main if you
haven't got a big billet then I guess
you got to reach out to mentors and
stuff like that outside of the group
link dean if you ever do that not at
that point no I mean oh it's quite lucky
that there like a lot of these small
firms there was one or two guys that
have been there forever billion loads
and then the rest were just on the churn
so and were these people willing to help
yeah I mean yes to begin with but like
everything like like I always say like
them if you keep asking and you keep
giving advice and then you keep not
tight not taking it or not applying it's
not they're gonna get yeah they turn the
tap off that no after well and I really
felt that your back turning like you
know eventually this I make you know you
figure it out kind of thing really oh
okay and that's right probably because
you can only teach people so much guy
yeah if they're not listening but yeah
if you certainly if you've got a big
bitter or a top perform or or if not
then you've got direct or someone in
your office then you know I don't mean
in an ass clicky way but I think if
these guys have done the things you've
done you can gravitate around them and
it's sound advice yeah I do honestly
think nothing don't yet don't don't sort
of be scared to ask for help yes a lot
of people may be worried about that you
know I mean yeah yeah I think that's a
that's right you mean a scope help and
then obviously follow the guidance and
apply it yeah and then get your heady
and I think a lot of employers will give
you a lot of credibility lot of rope if
they see you really put you back into it
and I've heard your snoring a few times
you were grafting yeah when you weren't
Billy not you know they could you get a
lot of ripe for that I think specially
in that table especially that's of a
solid business like yeah I'm hired no no
no I mean yet okay so teacher active
just quickly just get me out obviously
how many people do you manage now my
direct management now is a team of
twelve fourteen twelve oh yeah yeah yeah
and you built that up over either six
years five five six years yeah
now yeah okay all right before before we
go into that management piece just I'll
just sum I'd love to get your thoughts
on Sabina temp recruiter yep what I only
did perm yeah so like in your obviously
now I'm seeing obviously the temporal
critics come through and we take on and
this whole period like what are the sort
of common mistakes and things that
temporal creatures do typically do
they're beginning of their recruitment
journey which I'm sure you did yeah I
think if you're a temp recruiter I mean
no certainly on firms you you know yours
after jobs and stuff like that but in
temp there's never a shortage of jobs
you know never a shortage of jobs so I
think sometimes you can get to hang on
to jobs you can't fill mmm and you've
obviously got to work very closely with
your candidate base because you can have
a role or a candidate but unless they're
the right role the right kinda like you
still don't have a deal so I think you
know knowing to put enough graft into
the right roles when it when it's
covered cover it when you can't cover it
do something about it but then stick it
on the back burner and you've got to
work a lot more in your cycle you know
you got to make sure you've always got
pipeline coming through both candidate
Anne Klein and then you've got a run
through them and eventually you get some
matchup you know you get a client it
can't match up with a client job and
vice versa and then once you've got some
clients on board obviously you can start
to build the kind of availability they
need around them in education is you
know its geographical to a certain
degree you can build availability for
them and then you can go back and ask
some more kind of thing but in the early
days like everybody you just begging for
any bit of work you can get you're after
some data we have in education Marc
rather than gee paver and to get some
days on the board and you want to get
anything you can fix but later on you
start to learn to work on the right
staff and put the rights inevitably send
people's people putting too much effort
into jobs that typically aren't gonna
yeah even jobs they can't feel or they
work on a job for too long that's not
been you know it's not likely to feel
very easily which means they could have
brought on five jobs that would have
been easier to fill in the same space so
I think you know I was liking it so
that's plate-spinning you know like
there's the plates on them
the sticks mmm but you have to give got
a lot things up in the air and then you
give them a little twist there under
there and then you touch something else
and do stuff like that and if you can't
fill that particular job now but you've
got an ad out you've got some searches
out for it you know even that same job
will come back around in a few weeks or
or a similar job somewhere else so
you've got to always juggle your
candidates and your clients so I think
you got to do is enough candidate work
at the same time as enough client work
and then you've got to start putting
them together you know I think that
sounds really they but it's kind of an
art to get everything moving and once
you've got that machine right then you
want a billion machine on you and that's
why it is a temp recruit once you get it
right you can do quite well quite
quickly you know yeah so ok so typically
what what people fall short on quite
early or what people will experience as
a challenge is yeah balancing there yeah
the client work the candidate work yeah
so business development in the temp
context yeah how difficult is that well
you get both sides having I mean it's
definitely difficult especially in
education it's an old market is
established it's very mature which is
reliable and stable so it's a good
business you know getting in yeah but I
mean public sector generally you know
public sector money they don't really
like change the creatures of habit so -
doing a new client on board when seeming
every agency is the same you know he's
tricky but um I'll go back to like the
the basics Emmys like when there's a sea
of average recruiters if you're half
decent is very easy to stand out you
know making sure you've got some value
and everything you say to your client
making sure you never pick up the phone
without some purpose and making sure you
have a clear message when you dial even
when the early days is easily stands you
apart from you know there's a lot of
consultants coming through all the time
that are written poorly trained and
really I can imagine in the tempo again
if I'm wrong but like can really just be
a lot really transactional oh yeah it is
yeah totally it's it's best fit a lot of
time yeah yeah leisure like Steven like
you available yeah yeah I'm available
have you got this qualification can you
do this but yeah I can can you do Friday
or Sunday where Bosch Dunn's next yeah
yeah yeah even within now sometimes I
need someone for one hour and 45 minutes
so all that how
obviously there's an element of that
person being suitable but is it more
literally on estate have you got the
right credentials to do this job it
depends on both doesn't it I mean it
depends on what you need for a
short-term thing most of the time
they're looking for obviously they have
to be certain stand did a job but beyond
that can you deliver can you get someone
to me in 45 minutes which obviously is
led about availability in the work
you've done before that and then about
your organization have you prepped them
who will they be it will they pick up
the phone if you ring do you have a
relationship with them I think it's
quite unique I think education and maybe
medical a bit like that but other than
that I think it's quite deadly only ones
that well I know but how just fun this
topic I'm interested again you can talk
about the attractive and how yeah that's
about it there but like if that if
that's lit if that's literally the case
in terms of the relationships that in
your word teachers have recruiters yeah
like how can you how can you start call
over in more of a relationship focused
approach you know I mean yeah well I I
can carry on doing what I'm doing yeah
and like it's gonna it's gonna work
right because if I call the right person
that can do the job then yeah I'm gonna
make money but like I mean yeah well in
in our market at least where there's so
much demand I mean most most clients in
their case schools will probably have at
least two or three agencies it's they're
going to maybe two or three on reserve
after that so if somebody's priority one
agency in that there's always a period
when they're gonna drop the ball some
like someone's not have to stand it
basically is sometimes you're gonna say
no you know what today I stand it's not
where it needs to be I'm not going to
fill that today go call somebody else
because I'd rather you know that and
then me send someone I think might not
do a good job
and that's so powerful maybe if you say
to him that I've got a guy but you know
he's not my number one so York or
whatever often they'll take it anyway
but at least you're getting that trust
with the clients so you know won't they
send anything ever but inevitably when
it's peak it's busy especially for us to
winter seasons and stuff like that
people make bad calls we all do and it's
that time when they've made a bad call
that you can make a better call your
availability can be stronger than theirs
and you can get a chance over them and
then it's like okay they might use you
both equally and then you know
everyone's always like stock market like
someone's always moving up yeah and then
what about I'm just I'm just thinking
like that like how'll I know how quick
is that like is it like mental Colin
lights even on the intensive education
most of us in early we're in at least
from 6:30 7:00 in the morning really
yeah yeah we're early doors may you know
before the Sun's up we're up and in the
office and in that period we might send
out you know 30 40 50 workers on their
way with in with an hour and a half so
so yeah you can imagine you gotta get
you know you don't know where the jobs
are coming from you than aware the
candidates are you travel to deal with
you've got all sorts of things so you
need a prepared workforce you need to
better get to the point you can expect a
certain amount of work you know
obviously as you in in in the game for a
long while you know certain clients will
call you then at certain levels or
requirements but you know if the snow
should hit or if you know the flu bugs
going around or something then there's
only so much you can do so so a lot of
it is about organization in this job
because you need to you always need to
be ready to fill the jobs before you've
got the jobs almost sudden so and that
and that's that and that's down to
cultivating and having a living and
breathing candidate pool yeah always a
live database you speak to you daily you
know you've got to stay on top of
everything so you know obviously there's
medium and long term stuff as well yeah
so like I'm listening the foreman if I'm
a temp recruit right now what you're
saying is all great mate sense now from
a technical career right now and I'm
like right on like how can i as you said
it you can stand that quite easily
because there's a lot of [ __ ] of careers
oh yeah right particularly I can imagine
I mean obviously it has that reputation
mark and I can just imagine in there in
the temp landscape is just so easy just
to be transactional so like I'm listen
right now what's your advice for you to
start really cultivating that candidate
pulling those things in relation to the
canons because ultimately that's that's
what's gonna stand you again yes I think
you know when the clients ask unique you
can't deliver unless you have a
candidate base so your candidate base is
important like you'd imagine and your
candidate base will only go further for
you work at the rate you've got I've got
a different job if you probably know you
they trust you same as always
you got a you got to speak to them at
the times you know when you haven't
given them work or when you know even if
things haven't gone well you know
sometimes temps don't do what they're
supposed to do they mess up the job you
need to tell them that you need to
address that in the right ye but
obviously you still need to you know you
need to address the issue with them but
you still want to give them respects as
otherwise they'll just send your divorce
mail the next day and that's a game over
so you've got to find a way obviously of
keeping your workforce happy and working
first of all and then secondly you know
paying them well we're paying them right
looking after them going the extra mile
for on where you can and I think like
anything you know humans are inherently
good if you do good things and good
people they'll do the same back to you I
think and how again I'm thinking again
correct if I'm wrong but yeah ten market
like how vulnerable is a temporary right
now for their competitor to wring out
one of your teachers let's say and say
Stephen
yeah I know we don't always work
together but I've got this job and it's
paying ten quid the now more than
Stephen I know you work Stephen blah
blah blah yeah and I just said Stephen
so I said but how are you to that yeah
in in the in-demand parts of the job
yeah absolutely yeah yeah that's very
real I mean most people are thinking any
jobs won't move for just money alone so
I think unless how can you avoid being
wonderful to that so I'm trying to get I
think you know like always a place
people in a job then enjoy a fair or
appropriate sense so much so it's more
difficult for them to make a decision to
live yeah yeah yeah and the same if you
got a suitable job for them if they're
not travelling five hours away because
you wedge some role you know there's no
good to see if decent job they'll be
less susceptible to hi Stephen the H
I've got job as Penn folk with an hour
more are you open to it
yes you know I'm in a really good job
yeah an equally like you know as a temp
agency we need their candidates and they
need us you know because they know their
assignments only gonna run for so long
zone they also have you've done a good
job don't want to spoil their
relationship with you and don't get me
wrong they've got to work and they got
to pay their bills so that's always
gonna be first but if they can keep that
relationship with you and you know
sometimes the company and say look I've
been offered this job or whatever it
does pay more and you know you can just
be rule of them so that you know what
give me weeks notice that might work
better for you it's better if that's the
case go do that or
you know come back to me when that's
finished we'll get him back on board or
sometimes you say that don't worry I'll
speak to clients if we can get you some
more or I'll do that in this case but
again it's not that relationship minutes
like if you're honest and open with them
they as long as you've got got though
but then they will be with you and
hopefully they'll come to you and tell
you that something how can you get that
than me I think I'd be a bit more
downfield
it's just treating people with respect
you know calling them back letting her
know you know I know it's all very basic
stuff but it usually isn't it's like you
know making sure you speak to me into
today how they got on how was the Simon
understanding it requirements really
what kind of do they want to go making
sure you pay right I mean I was
definitely guilty in my very early days
in my last them but you know the
focusing on margin too much and not
necessarily focusing on the right job
for the right person which that happens
and it is if you do that soon enough
your workforce will disappear and
rightly so and just help me understand
yeah a simple question but so when when
you say that you're saying that you was
more focused on making sure that you was
making more money out the relationship
yeah necessary then making sure the
teacher was getting the most that they
possibly could yes nobody is that and
that's obviously people quite prone to
oh yeah yeah I mean just so it's like
crystal clear yeah just because there
might be a lot of panelists yeah it's
like just even I got this job yeah we'll
pay this this yeah we'll pay X yeah and
then you will find a teacher yeah so
obviously depends on the the nature of
the job and who can do it obviously but
if you're if your charge rate is fixed
which sometimes it is sometimes it's
variable but your pay rate is flexible
okay and a very inexperienced or a very
experienced candidate could do it
obviously they have different pay
expirations
they obviously won't meet to do the job
to the same level but sometimes that job
doesn't need that full experience so
yeah I mean you can choose in that
situation to impress your client with a
with a winner of a candidate who's going
to do a great job or you can choose to
more margin and that's always the
balance or balance fear yeah or more
really serious about the quality of your
bail ability at that point but you know
that is a task and if you're on if
you're on the quick win scenario like a
lot of us are in the early days you can
make those call greater focus on the
mind yeah
I think when you when you don't do that
you know of recent recent many years
since I learned the game and now I train
people you know I'll say you know pay
people a fair wage you're doing a fair
job and that's not just cliche stuff
it's just it's common sense
yeah so then so that was gonna be my
next question like someone that maybe is
susceptible to that yeah and that could
be a real reason as to why there may be
losing candidates to their competitors
and stuff like how yeah how can how can
someone start approaching that then
literally just just be really mindful of
what again the paid affair am i right i
beginning off the cast you know how much
do you need what do you when previously
no exact in line with what they should
because sometimes you might have caught
from an agency when they were well under
paying him in which case if you can put
them right you should that's them good
that's a good time to do that you know
yeah put the pick pay rate right let
them know that as well if you manage to
gonna go she ate a little bit more than
they perhaps normally should have done
again so if you let them know that you
know if they're if they're pay rate
should be X and you managed to get why
tell them that you've done that for them
and you know you can't expect people to
know the market it sounds like a lot of
a lot of like really making sure that
you've got that reliable living and
breathing candidate Paul yeah being
honest and like yeah it's I'm assuming
that a lot of your competitors are very
susceptible to not be in that because
you know I mean it's just like yes go
right back and I know what the margin is
blah blah blah yeah and it I can imagine
one so it can be very easy be like you
make that placement and this lot are
more good the margin on that [ __ ]
wicked yeah I'm not absolutely buzzing
off that but and then like you just
long-term way susceptible to like you've
just way under pay that person whatever
yeah yeah absolutely yeah and obviously
that can happen I mean there's good and
bad in every agency like like like you
know I mean the good the guys are doing
good or have done good for a long period
of learning these lessons long time ago
you know yeah but yeah you got to kind
of paint well and I do believe in
charging well as well if you've done a
good job you've done a good service if
your client I think you know you do yeah
so in a candidate LED market I think you
know you push that on the client if you
want the more margin rather than on the
on the canvas because candidates walk
just walk elsewhere or even if they
don't know part of it till these islands
finish and we never hear from them again
so hmm
no there's no longevity nazar okay
that's my thoughts in him yeah so before
we go into the management piece coffee
yeah it definitely would've been some
learnings and that yeah throughout your
career again I'm thinking of like how
how how do you help your team now then
yeah how did you help yourself
yeah become better at spinning these
plates because I can I can imagine like
because what was like the peak time make
other neither pizza man you had X amount
of people out working for you yeah would
you say like doesn't like I don't know I
don't know if it's on a date or a weekly
where you have like 80 people out well
yeah Steven you know I mean yeah how how
did how have you got better manage it
do you know what made a lot of that is
if you set it up right in the beginning
that's much easier if yeah if you get
good people into suitable roles and you
can't always do that but as suitable as
possible paying them well candidates
happy the clients happy you have far
less problems you know if you're if
you're skimping on everything and you're
trying to wedge square pegs in the round
logs every single week something's going
wrong someone's dropping out your back
feeling you know then you can't get you
can't build a desk like that you you you
get to a certain number whatever that is
and then you going up 10 down 10 up 10
down Tim because always something's
dropping off so and that's because what
did you say sorry because they haven't
got things on at the bigger yeah because
you know somebody's walking out because
um paying them right or yeah a client
saying this is too much we've dropped it
or someone's got poaching online all of
those things happen if you've not done
them foundations right so I that make
sense having good principles about this
is how I want to run my desk or if you
see says that we run our business and
that I stole as a lot yeah and all of
that contributes you've been there to
manage your day bed because yes yeah
yeah I mean you still have problems the
bigger the bigger your workforce gets
you know people do want to leave people
moons you can change on that's normal
but they're informed and if they're in
that you know planning stage I you know
I want to moving on new job want to find
they want to leave this they keep you
time whereas if it's on fire they're
telling you I'm walking out now or
whatever yeah and you get much less
reaction so most Tim recruits learn
early on you know those kind of
shortcuts just lineage to more headache
and you can't build a successful debt
that's like that so you know looking
after people paying it right and being a
good communication like if you know
feedback from the client is that they've
you know they're not on point or they've
not been right
make sure you feed that back because I
want you to say that but obviously
you'll be diplomatic about how you say
you want them to acknowledge it but not
upsetting me Isis how did you help
people structure their day then like
because I'm sure that's got to be on
point you said you've got yeah how so
how how do you sort of help your guys
now and throughout your career how have
you sort of structure your day to give
you the best possible chance of yeah
obviously there's not a lot it's really
important for any Tim work and
especially in us and education so our
market lends itself quite comfortably to
that because there's certain actions to
take place at certain days so for us we
have a kind of cool way of working X
amount of time is the X amount of time
is that so everybody works in that which
gives its energy in the room when it's
sales time we're talking help me out
blocks out time yeah activities blocked
outside lots up times typically depends
your they are in a couple of hours and
fine our Fred mean a couple of hours
back on the phone and everyone there's
at the same time yeah yeah typically
reasonably structured yeah because one
it gets it drives efficiency like you're
kind of forced to be reasonably
efficient and to certainly with the
phone time you know no one wants to make
calls in the dead environment you know
you want a feed of everyone's energy and
if you're saying okay right everybody's
on the phone from X to X then you get
that energy lift in the room and the
light that comes off there if it's
winning then it feels good simply have
your team then you said efficient
there's that actually generated yeah I
mean thanks the planning away from you
to a degree so I think you've got to do
X you next time then that gives you a
window doesn't it you've got to get that
done and because everyone else is doing
it around you at those times as well so
those kind of things are are forced to
get the core activities because it's a
360 recruiting attempt market there's
lots of places to spin okay so you've
got to them you've got to stay on top of
them by by helping your team are giving
them the best structure yeah
but outside of that me personally I'm
and the guys now you know like everybody
like lists and making sure you're on top
of things
you know I bother all and thinking some
Jim Jim Ryan like never start the day
before you have it finished you just
like I love these little cliches and
things I think it's really good like the
like before I leave every day I know one
of my main things I need to get done
tomorrow in amongst the normal
activities and then as long as I can get
them done than enough Joe what like you
brought you prioritize tasks
100% yeah because obviously watching the
office participating in the stuff and
taking care of my own stuff you need to
make sure you know otherwise about they
can wipe your whole day like on it so
yeah so making sure you've got your your
priorities right and for me personally
like keeping them to no more than four
or five things and making sure that
there's plenty of them it's gone wrong
room because stuff inevitably will go
wrong so you need you need a bit of
space to do with the does if I'm
listening right now if I'm a temp
recruiter on managing a temple grooming
team I mean this is obviously applicable
to someone who's a pan recruit or
whatever but you what you what you've
really seen I've experienced this myself
when I was in recruitment and yeah
everyone sort of sporadically develop
made the decision to do like the typical
core hours and yeah definitely helps
especially when you're in a smaller
environment where everyone's on the
phone it does drive energy blah blah
blah yeah so that you so yeah if you're
listening right now and there is
everyone's got their own structure
whatever to think about how you can
weave in a team structure that actually
benefits everyone because enables
everyone to focus on what you should
know our key activities that you drive
the outcomes that you want for your team
and yourself Honduras in May I think you
know I do think I mean I've always been
ten but I do think that kind of
structure works well for temp or perm
maybe you're in a in the job market
maybe in a candidate lit market but
whatever the activity is if you can get
a certain routine where that has to
happen you do it as a team that's fairly
non-negotiable then you drive that
energy you drive that activity success
with that because I I can remember
because that must be that's a process as
well cause like let's say tomorrow
you're like right guys like let's say
hunt that in before but right guys from
7:00 to 9:00 9:00 a.m. yeah all we're
doing is speaking to teachers right yeah
but and then you've got Tom in your team
is like Stephen man I've got get the CVR
but how strict house trigger do you be
with it pretty strict I mean if you
didn't know you could set your watch by
it so it's blue strict in your fish but
like anything you know if you're an
experienced recruiter
I'll trust your judgment and know that
CV needs to go now yeah so I'm not gonna
tell I talk but yes I do it so that's
fine but other than those really strict
Pedersen yeah one person
understand usually they're trying to
send a CV that you know it's got to be
safe now but they won't look at it for
five hours anyway so it really doesn't
happen so unless their judgment is on
point to be able to make sure that is
the right people willing to challenge it
and go yeah I understand but can that
way yeah you can turn after is it gonna
have a room for you in a two hour period
and you saying you're midway like will
it really make a difference if you send
it in one hours time most of the time
the answer's no and if they're genuinely
if it's the right kind a but the right
job and they're literally about to go
and look at it right now
then of course send it it doesn't make
you know I'm not trying to win any ego
he's just trying to bring bring
efficiency but yeah i stanch a question
pretty regimented but with a most some
degree over so management yep
continual Billings yeah it's a lot more
place to deal with that and so I think I
remember seeing your LinkedIn post no
wild like send that in the Creveling
wrong but your branch was like one of
the highest performers at one point yeah
in a year right so we were brunch in the
air and top biller and we had a good
year last year we won pretty much
everything in our annual okay this year
we won you know half top producers and
stuff so let's unpack yeah yeah like
what what if I'm this right now I'm a
manager whatever like yeah what were
this what would this or like or failures
that you're making that you recognized
that they obviously nabel's you to
become a better manager and achieve
these things of like and any sort of key
failures that you like if I knew that
whatever that would be my thinking is if
you're building a team like me obviously
the hires you buy when you buy them and
how they fit in the team how you support
them how long you keep them there the
real driving factors in the early days
about getting headcount in obviously and
then the right headcount she's way more
important than headcount
and then after that that C word that
culture you know you've ever winning
culture where everybody chips in and a
lot of the works done for you or you
have a miserable culture where you're
putting out fires that front and center
so and I've got that right and wrong
both times over
years you know but like everything the
more time you do it you learn from the
mistakes you make you know you know you
can definitely get too invested in
sometimes in personal relationships of
people that you really like that just
aren't going to make it and yeah I
genuinely believe you do it that you do
them a distrust astir service if you
drag them on the months and months of
you know if they're not going to make it
so being real with people back where
they are but then also sometimes people
that really can make it that aren't
putting the right work in having the
right chats with them keeping them on
board you know and and progressing them
along I fully believe as a sales manager
you should be speaking to your team
regularly if not daily how do you
structure it as you know we might have a
session a whiteboard session you might
top and tell the session before the call
session you know just maybe get everyone
in the boardroom let's talk over some
topic some challenges people having you
know and I might leave that I might get
them to leave that sometimes I often do
that weekly I do that personally as well
it's what the typical things that you'd
go over and that that's interesting
no one's actually said that yeah it
might be that maybe people are
struggling to get to a certain level in
this hour maybe to certain to shortly
objection yeah objections come up quite
a lot being gatekeepers and yeah you
know those kind of all common stuff
really and sometimes it's the same stuff
over and over again okay sometimes is
the same answer package the same way
sometimes I'll even let each other on it
but I think having them regular training
sessions and certainly if you're in if
your type of business has to do a lot of
cool volume I think topping and tail in
the session what do you mean by often
before the session starts dress the
floor you know set up objectives what
we're going to do if there's something
seasonal in the market you know as it's
quite predictable there's busy periods
and slow periods and resignation windows
and stuff like that so letting your team
know about that obviously some
experienced guys will know about that
long some won't if it's needed set
individual objectives you know keep it
energy keep getting energy rush keep
objectives know and then the key thing
is obviously the golden rule which
managers don't learn to to ladies it's
follow-up after you know it's not really
like it's all well and good setting up a
session but you've got to close the
session you know if you sign up tell
part yeah you've got a tailor you
say okay well this is what we said we
were gonna do go around okay how did you
do it did you not and so obviously
someone have been successful someone
have been not someone we're hiding under
the desk hoping you don't point at them
asking them
yeah but if you're not called to
objective and this is even you know even
for me and everyone else if you're not
asked at the end of it well did you do
it mate
you know then there's no consequence is
it not I'm trying to say it's like yeah
yeah and if you your help
yeah so I think if you're running call
sessions at least topping and tallying
the sessions in the busy period today
it'd be so how objective laughing that's
what your advice nan nan shared that so
yeah give me just to help people
listening light so you said about the
objectives I'd really like that
well I'm thinking actually that's really
interesting you said that because if I
think of I remember few times where my
old director he would he would show he
would share of us that he hasn't been
quite happy with the business
development sessions and then didn't
quite right blah blah you know that
would be after three or four sessions if
that makes sense yeah I think that's a
really interesting point you said so
just break it down simply like a typical
tailing of a session or they closing on
the session would be what exactly like
would you then communicate several at
the same time yeah so it depends if in
the work laughing but let's say there's
activities to help you know which can
happen sometimes and if there's
opportunity just get some fun let's get
some energy into it a game order and
then set up what we want to do
communally everybody and then as the
session goes on will let go there
typically if you've got a two-hour
session you might want to touch on it
halfway yeah yeah people how they're
going and then the back end of it if
you've got a big team you're not gonna
go for everyone one by one but you want
to pick out one or two people usually
got an eye whose done it who hasn't
pick out a couple of successes so the
guys can see the benefit what you're
doing pick out one or two failures and
asking what they've learned you know we
don't want it in in a negative way but
so they can see all right you know what
I really didn't do quite as asked some
other guys did they've got some value
out of it and you know they can and you
work around your group like that I think
that's a good way of managing the last
team you know and I like that interest
them
so you mentioned culture yeah how have
you got better at nailing that because
I'm sure a lot you mate
you know other than recruitment it's
like one of the things that fascinates
me the most you know I mean you must see
it a lot network with a lot of
businesses but you know you can
instantly see a winning culture you know
you look at sports teams and you look at
even retail environments and and certain
thing you can see where there's winners
and stuff that happens and you can see
the opposite can't you you know certain
people just can't catch a break and I
think you're firm if you're able to
create that within your business it's
really good and obviously you know
you're talking about the actual business
itself it's just about those personal
relationships isn't it's choosing the
right people to work with people you
know did they complement each other how
do you pick the right people me how have
you got bare of that yeah learning is
always you know you got to look at I
think the character fits really
important okay how did you how did you
how did you look for that and measure
that and look for that in an interview
well you got to know you people first of
all really on a good level and then
after that I think you know I think you
can get a lot from an interview asking
people the right questions to really get
them to open up and I think that's as
important as if they can build or not
you know I don't care if you can with
tons and days on the board if if you're
gonna be you know I use that word of
cancer to the business if you're gonna
write every inside out then that's no
good to me you know I'd rather you have
a moderate billa that's going to
complement the business and everyone
works together because otherwise it's
only a matter of time before that we've
got about as far as buying cancel me I
think you just them you know any
mistakes don't you we need mean you've
hired some bad calls I mean generally
number one role you know if I don't like
them then there's a good chance my team
won't like the Merriam I know how it all
on my team and I really is I haven't
hired many people I don't like but like
everybody when you want to build a
business you hire some people that
you're not so sure on and that doesn't
like that pretty quickly yeah that
becomes pretty evident and so I think if
you like them if they fit within the
team I guess if you're not sure you can
bring them in but usually after a while
you can get a good you know the social
test is a good one and it if you would
go to a point where you go bowling
would they get on with everybody would
they know not pre hire but I think glass
I was there yeah could you go for a
drink of them could you cheer take lunch
of them would you would you run out of
things to say pretty quickly or would
you be an engaging I think if they're on
that level if you get on with them and
in my case it was here I hired all my
team then they're gonna get on me and
I'm gonna get over them most of the time
and I think it's not like it's a
popularity contest different people have
different
is but I think as long as they're
complement in your current cohort of
energy rather than dragging it down
how achievable is that when you get like
you've got a pretty big team now right
sure lead that person surely if you
think I surely the person you bring in
how like can they be can they get on
with Thane for people yeah definitely
get on with yeah you're gonna be best
buddies you know no I'm sure everyone's
you know not sure mates in there right
so they don't necessarily need that but
I think you know can they get on can
they work together can they share common
goals can they can they complement the
business together absolutely some people
will get on with some people more than
others and that's fine and then like you
say if you've worked in the business of
high turnover as somebody drops out of
that somebody leaves or whatever they
drop out the process the the culture
changes again doesn't it if it's a big
ego or a big presence or maybe a
not-so-good one moves things change and
relationships change and I think you
know I find it really fascinating so for
me as a manager I think you're always
juggling that and you know you're trying
to tweak it and you know things like
seeing plans got a big thing for me we
regularly don't get too attached to our
seat in my office I don't I don't like
that way why is it why why because I
think you know you get too comfortable
don't you get sat next they're the same
NIU's that always and I think if you get
the top Billis at next the top biller
they will do their own thing you stick
it off villain extra trainee Billa he
will react different to her mother and
vice versa so I'm always moving the
seats around like it's like gingka in my
office you know at least once every
couple of months we move seats really
yeah even me I move wherever I need to
go you know out of the good spots and
sit in the corners whoever but I think
every time you do that well I always
fees move the seats what happens instant
energy change instantly really instantly
mate yeah yeah everyone moves the desk
moved the trolley over there addressing
the doors and drawers and it's a
different location and the energy
changes much better sometimes worse
moving around again you know yeah as
long as you said from the outset I
always say you know this is how this is
how we have it so um it's not a big deal
you know I've been to some place and
doing that and you get things fro now
it's always like the culture set like
that people look forward to it they'll
get people ask me now let me I mean move
around I've got to here and I like so
little things like that okay anything
else like that then that could be I
think that's often that's really
interesting unique point is there
anything else that
notice that had a quite cool interesting
impact on culture yeah in New York team
things yeah empowering people stuff like
that specifically asking people to look
over someone and you know putting them
arm around them whether it's emotional
support or women I go through a tough
time you know I think just playing those
relationships not like I'm trying to pay
like voodoo and control everything but
just knowing when you know that guy over
there could do really well I see he's
going down the wrong path you know not
making the right choices you know put
someone around him you know he's a good
egg that could definitely win sin in the
right you know in the right way so we
can bring him back on track and then
he'll feel better about it you'll
respect the person they'll help them and
you know you can't get it all right but
I think that's the moving beast is to
try and manage those pieces of the
jigsaw as much as you can okay but
crucially if you do get a bad egg you
know and I'm Adam and I've seen and I'm
sure you've but with a few you know as
fast as its sense well you got to remove
that or challenging yeah yeah in you
know sensible way but yeah yeah okay me
yeah secure survive and thrive yeah if
you're all that tiles yeah that's
calling it what are you yeah that's the
one question I get off the most actually
I know it's made live what comes to mind
when someone asks you what why did you
write this bit right so a bit I've been
asked it a few times so number one
because I can't I would see in my job on
a train kiss and I do a lot I've been
saying it a lot like ah sure right but
one day like you know II go I should
write a book one day yeah number two
because obviously I see a lot of common
traits for me in my attempt sick there
is the flower I tried to be as well
informed as possible but yeah a lot of
people walk down the wrong path quite
often make the same mistakes as stuff
that I said there's a lot of common
things that occur but probably finally
it sounds a bit mushy mushy really but
and you know recruitments been pretty
good to me mate so you know I've been
able to live a reasonably good life go
some nice places do some nice things and
you know I said to him to start you know
I'm not graduate I'm not you know got
the best thing on paper and I've been
known to do really well for it and I
genuinely thought you know I don't know
if I'll do this forever you know
- do you think the core of why I
announce of create that for yourself
just because your recruitment has a lot
to give you've got a lot to offer it
don't you you know there's a lot of
opportunity financially and meaning the
right places and stuff like that so you
know it's done really well for me now
I've got over the hurdle and you know I
said I'm gonna be a recruiter when I'm
50 or whatever so I think you [ __ ]
out one more person can live you know
the good things that I've had and do to
plate the things that I've had and it
helps somebody who's struggling oh you
might be getting fired to not get fired
or or to start to build well then I
think it's pretty cool that that's I
think that's gray and I think what you
also do there's actually given people
reality of what what's involved yeah
yeah I mean I've been pretty brutal in
it yeah well you've got to be in that
yeah I mean I because it's all the
things I didn't get told and I was naive
enough to believe in all of that and
where I cannot confirm what I believe is
true and where I cannot deny you know
the rubbish you're told and set the
record straight as I see it and so yeah
and that's it you know I'd like to be
always challenged like to be doing stuff
where I've got on top of my game here in
my current business I'm running I'm like
okay cool I'm gonna I'm gonna write a
book and okay you know I want to do
things so just just just to let everyone
know listen so light so how you
structure this is secure so that's
getting your job in recruitment yeah and
survive that's surviving your first six
yeah so it's I pictured it as being your
intro to recruitment so secure survive
thrives things like you say getting into
recruitment which is how to understand
the things if you know nothing about if
you haven't even thought about it before
or if you're only just looking at you
know things like how to apply for a job
where to find the jobs common mistakes
and interviews how to structure your CV
if you haven't got the perfect CV like I
have all those kind of things
survive for me was a big thing and you
know but I've heard some of your
previous podcast some guys did quite
alright and had an Easy Rider
yeah how horrible time like me so I
genuinely call it survive you know
you're going to get through that period
that's basically through your probation
for me and again doing the right things
at the right times and little tips and
things
tips and tricks that will help bide your
time if you genuinely want to do the job
but perhaps you're not where you need to
yet and then Friday's probably you know
probably the bit with I'm most proud of
you know it's the bit where I genuinely
believe like was saying to you before we
started this thing you know everybody
should set themselves objective and
becoming top bidder if that's your you
know if you're going to be a biller you
may as well be the top Billa or a shoot
for it where do you think most people
fall short and getting to that point um
I think a lot its mentality may you know
I hear a lot now like it's acceptable to
not be that good mmm
and I don't mean that in a bad way like
you know there's plenty of space for a
good solid bill uh but I think because
we start pitching it as medium then a
lot of people on you Chiefs mulch and I
like that so my mentality is if you're
going to come into recruitment like most
do to earn good money that only comes
when you deliver good Billings and this
you're going to do you know management
or that kind of thing but so if that's
the case you definitely should try and
get there and from day one if you're
thinking about applying recruitment you
just started today that would be my one
message to man shoot for the top shoe
feel it's like Villa find out who the
top biller is make that your goal and
start working towards it because in my
in my experience in this business
teacher acting very successful business
you know we've been going you know 15 16
years the top bill is there is toppers
in the industry for the years I mean
they were doing six seven times the
Billings that I was doing in my previous
firm and I thought I was good then and
what would you put that down to monster
yeah a lot of this mindset yeah it's
just simply you know you
I tell you the simplest thing I always
say that the cells achievers Club what
everyone call it the sales club in my
last business was exactly double in this
new business so I came for the other
ones like I don't know how I can do that
all but mobile really in a sort of what
you mean like what you saw in your last
job yeah you know a lot of places have
like get to X level and you can get
trees a couple of what you need to get
it did the figure was double well so I
was like man I'm maxed out now you don't
I mean what happens is you just you know
you know about the paradigm thing you
know your paradigms like how you think
about things just get moved done yeah
your goal was performing at my neck
saying like that two hour two hour
marathon recent and so I think all the
time you do that so I think starting to
clear out set you know some of you will
become
better some of you I but I think having
that clear objective if that's what you
want to do you should shoot for it man
because it it can be done and even if
you've got long-established top builders
like if you worked in the medium-sized
firms like like we did at the beginning
you know sometimes like guys have been
there for years with the one around you
like that has that mentality that's
difficult in that did you know to be
that mentality you knew if they aren't
you yeah I mean there's no shortage of
inspiration on LinkedIn is there me or
in this book they are in this book not
obviously we're all so well connected
now not yet I think you I think it's
really interesting when you say Matt I
think yeah it's very easy to say now the
criminal long game yeah it's like you
gotta be patient
yeah which you have but the same time
just like less not obviously yeah put
down the the sort of mark as to where we
can get to and it's never gonna be the
same as it was like a dream I disagree
fully and I think you know I've got a
lot of people you know because I think
it's there for the taking man there's
always a top biller there's always a top
biller and even in a declining market
there's always there's always more to
get and I think that mindset to go after
it from the beginning like I said before
worst case - no you don't get it well
you become a number three it's not too
bad isn't it you know and then the
following year you'll get it because
usually top builders have their place at
the top you know if they've been long
standing four to four years and you're
really hungry and you get number two
number three I'll guarantee you you -
you're gonna take it if you're hungrier
yeah so I think that's that's a lot of
that so that's that's my fabric of how I
think about South and how I approach it
and that's a lot what then fried it yeah
what what do you say this little key key
parts of the fried thing that you think
people most benefit from going for it
now nothing there's some some really
interesting pizza you've got a bit
continue to develop yourself
yeah it's acting like consistency is key
but like what will you say some of the
sort of key things in this section that
you think will get value out well the
biggest thing Newman is the gatekeeper
section is a lot better yeah I think
it's a lost art they don't know the mean
guy keeps anymore so yeah it's a getting
getting DMS or contacts on the phone and
I know that's harder or easier depending
away what sector you in but that there's
a load of good stuff in now I think it's
three chapters on that because I wrote a
lot about that well how do you get
through
how physically to get people on the
phone yet I love it yeah what do you
think what do you think people have
gotten like what's the word yeah they've
forgotten like I've like said I think I
think it's like the skills of getting
lost and they getting forgotten to be
passed down from generation to
generation
and so I think you know where we're
getting that digital age now it's more
acceptable to send an email to leave a
voicemail to pass the message I think
we're giving ourselves escape routes out
when actually it's not that hard mate I
mean yes it takes time yes it takes a
bit of effort but you got to really put
your head into it and apply it but it
can be done you know and it's not that
hard with the right effort so I think
you know tackling it from that that
attitude that you can get people on the
phone yeah then talk about control which
is really important for me you know
recruiter on the phone that get how new
or experienced you are that person wants
to speak to someone who's in control of
the job who will be added deliver for
them they want to know that you're not
an amateur and I don't care if it's your
first day or you know 10 years deep they
want to feel like they're speaking to
someone who knows what they're doing I
talk about what I call the yo-yo effect
which is quite common where people early
in their doors where they have one good
week one bad week or one good month one
bad notes and stuff like that about
consistency going to consist us your
results mindset because obviously you
know as you know you know you can have
days it can really break you so that
there's a lot of stuff in there just
about my attitude how I think about that
how to get the most out of the job you
know and I've got you know really good
feedback about actually mate you know on
this amount I think I think it's I think
it's great mate I think I mean a bit a
big driver for me was was with the
podcast is very much pretty much what
you said my if he can have one person
like I mean I definitely didn't have a
ten-year career recruitment mate as
everybody knows I got saw the
recruitment dream yeah I'd be for Rolex
and all that and none of that happened
right and I think there's I think I love
the fact and what's really exciting I
think is that more and more people are
willing to share myself yeah again like
this took time to confess on the entire
lot you know I mean nothing again
exactly and for you to be willing to do
that I think it's great mate and
um definitely be proud me I didn't you
know things like you know mate there's
enough market out there for all of us
I'm did we say I think that's probably
the mindset I don't believe in us right
this is a few people and I'm not just
saying stuff you know I don't have you
don't have to lose to me to win we can
both win hundred percent and if we can
work together we can both win better you
know so yeah right yeah I mean that's
just common sense I think you know yeah
I think as well like with that totally
agree I think we're I really relate with
that is like when I when I had sort of
had the genius decision with my
colleagues to start creating content
than that and yeah the first push back
straightaway was that sort of scarcity
mindset of well I know what far
competiting and they still are clients
who always lie you got back yourself and
yeah hundreds in May yeah do you know I
mean yeah hundred single back yeah yeah
okay mate so besides the book then yeah
we excited about me what's going on just
in your world yeah just got a future
mate you know I think you know his
opportunity there every day and then
talk about topical but like the bricks
it's tough I don't know what that could
mean but I think of genius isn't it
mm-hmm
you know things are gonna change in
marking everybody's market some are
gonna contract something gonna grow and
I think there's just opportunity out
there all the time you know and as I'm
getting better at my craft and you know
my guys are getting more experienced and
you know I just think this oh yeah I'm
always optimistic but you know I think
this there's always stuff out there to
get you know mmm now I finished finish
that I want to find something else cool
to do so basically yeah we discussed
before is that we did yet sameen Steven
were talking and Steven very kindly said
that he's willing to ultimately give
away some of his wisdom
besides this podcast obviously yeah
obviously I don't give away some of his
wisdom and his secure survive thrive yep
book in there in the shape of a period
of discounts in the price yeah when
Amazon yeah so what we need to do is
when when this podcast goes live would
ya be whenever it is but when it does go
live to 24 hours 24 hours yeah is like
the first day yeah this this Amazon give
you a certain amount of flexibility over
it which is incomplete but they
definitely allow you to discount it for
a certain
so we'll discount yeah we're gonna
discount this book yeah well you're
gonna know I'm not yeah we wait for 24
hours yep when this when this podcast is
worthy so if you've enjoyed this episode
you've enjoyed what you had to say
there's obviously a lot more in this
book cover so much an hour or so yeah
and then you've gotten the opportunity
to buy this book for a discounted price
and I'll put the link to and obviously
to purchase this in the in the episode
notes key thing and when I when I share
it on LinkedIn as well yeah and and then
the other thing that we wanted to do
yeah right was a couple of books the
line around vision or for now you've got
books lying around that you can give
away from a book style
[Laughter]
I've got five copies right here so we
work out we do it but I think we're
gonna I'm gonna do a post and when if is
this goes live we're trying to work out
how to do this before yeah if you head
over to it and just give it a like and
then basically our pics and people
steven is obviously we're gonna get a
picture yeah stealing's on a post that
the podcast is live yeah yeah and
basically if you like stevens post yeah
and you are then gonna pick a person at
random yet five people who ran them who
likes your post yeah are you gonna
deliver it personally you know cool yeah
I'll sign it for no charge to make that
crystal clear yeah and we're yeah so
when this goes live and this is
published there's gonna be an
opportunity to get this book at this
kind of price and then when you actually
share everyone that the podcast has gone
live yeah and if you like Stephens post
then there's gonna be an opportunity to
to get a free to get to get a free copy
yeah yeah yeah we commit and last
question yeah if you could communicate
every single recruit out there yeah they
listen they take on your advice pressure
could be a phrase or words what would
you say mate
I have that you know and the biggest
thing that I kind of learned and I say
to everyone and it's not my phrase as
usual by repeat your lies what you lack
in skill make up for in numbers that's
kind of that core thing and now it's not
new it's not cliche but if you're not
that good if the guy next to you twice
as good dile twice as much and you're
balancing huh that's kind of my core
message and if that's the case then the
gap between you will come down quickly
you'll learn faster and things like that
so that's kind of mine you could put me
on the spot I think that's what I say
but beyond that I think you know if
you're not Top Billing you want to be
you know genuinely work towards it man
you know don't let anyone tell you can't
be done don't let anyone you know put
doubts on you it can be done and I've
seen some long-standing builders get not
love the pigs and some guys that were
definitely underdogs do really well so
if you in your heart think you could be
really good or deliver really well you
know keep going I know like quest in and
out you know shoot me a message LinkedIn
I'll respond happy to help you know
legitimate Steven it's been a pleasure
thank you me